[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد مشاهد المباني
الحديثه في مناطق مختلفه بتركيا وهي تنهار
بفعل الزلزال المدمر اثار التساؤلات بشان
اسباب الانهيار ومعايير السلامه التي
رافقت هذه المباني وتشهيدها تحديدا في
تركيا بعد ان سويت هذه المباني بالارض
وقتل عشرات الالاف رغم ان المباني في
تركيا شهدت حديثا وحمل بعضها لفتاه كتب
عليها ان المبنى اكتمل وفقا لاحدث انظمه
تحمل الزلازل وعلى الرغم ايضا من ان
الزلازل كانت قويه الى ان الخبراء يشيرون
الى وجوب عدم انهيار المباني المشيده
بشكلنا صحيح سكان في تركيا قالوا ان بعض
المباني كانت تعرضت لاضرار في زلزال عام
1999 ولم تتم معالجه اضرارها كما نقلت
تقارير تركيا ان الحكومه قدمت منذ ستينيات
القرن الماضي حتى عام
2018 اعفاءات قانونيه لمباني تم بنائها
بدون شهادات السلامه وتنتقد تقارير محليه
التطبيق السيء لمعايير السلامه التي اقرت
عام 2018
ضمان تصميم المباني ضد الزلازل يرتكز الى
ثلاث خصائص رئيسيه المرونه اللازمه للصمود
في وجه الزلازل وتاخذ بالاعتبار ضروره
الصمود في وجه زلازل ضعيفه منع حدوث اي
اضرار تحتاج لاصلاح في المبنى جراء
الزلازل
توفر معدات خاصه بامتصاص الاهتزازات
مهمتها امتصاص اكبر قدر ممكن من الطاقه
الزلزاليه
الجمع بين التنظيم والسلامه عبر طوابق
تحمل الارتفاع ذاته واعمده على شكل شبكه
تفصيلها مسافات متساويه
نناقش هذا الجزء من الملف مع ضيوفنا من
عمان الدكتور محمود القريوت يبقى معنا كان
حضر معنا في الجزء الاول الباحث والمختص
في علمه رفض الزلازل من جديد اهلا بك من
اسطنبول المهندس المدني الاستشاري مظهر
شربجي اهلا بكم من جديد ضيوفي اذكر من
جديد باننا فتحنا المجال لمتابعينا
ليطرحوا الاسئله ليشاركونا
تساؤلاتهم واستفهاماتهم فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع وسناتي على بعض التعليقات على
تويتر على فيسبوك
وعلى كل منصات قناه العربيه
سنحاول ان ننقل لضيوفي بعض الاسئله وسابدا
معك من اسطنبول في الواقع استاذ مظهر
بعض الاسئله حول هذه النقطه من النقاش
يعني هناك من يسال هل الدول النشطه
زلزاليا معايير انشائيه للمباني يمكن
للدول ان تتخذها للحد من تداعيات الزلازل
على المباني وهل كثره الزلازل قد يصحبها
براكين بالدول الزلزاليه
سانقل لك الجزئيه الاولى من السؤال هل
هناك معايير انشائيه اكيد نعم هل تحترم في
المنطقه هذا هو السؤال
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين
ولزملائنا الدكتور محمود
نعم في كل دوله هناك كودات ومعايير
ومواصفات نقصد هنا بالكود هو النظام او
المعياري لوضع ليس فقط الابنيه ودراساته
ايضا يتعلق بالمواد البناء وفي التربه
والدراسات وكل ما يشمل هذا البناء من راسه
الى اساسه اذن المعير موجوده في تركيا بعد
عام 1999 وتم وضع تحديث لاكثر الكودات
الهندسيه الانشائيه
واخرها كان في 2018 اذا هناك في تطوير كل
ما تطورت المواد كل ما تطور ذلك لكن
المشكله ليست فقط بالكود المشكله في في ان
تتم تطبيق وتنفيذ هذه المعايير والمواصفات
على الارض يعني اذا كانت دراسه مدروسه
بشكل جيد وفقه معايير معينه وغير منفذه
يحدث هذا الاشكال الذي شاهدناه في اغلب
التي تعرضت للانهيارات للكوارث اذا بحثنا
في هذا في الدول العربيه ايضا نفس الوضع
في كودات زلزاله نعم
هناك طبعا تفاصيل يجب احترامها ولكن يقول
البعض دكتور محمود باننا علينا كذلك ان
نراجع بعض هذه التفاصيل هل علينا مراجعه
هذه التفاصيل بما يواكب التطور كذلك الذي
تعيشه الارض والذي تتبعونه حضراتكم كخبراء
نعم نعم لانه هناك يعني تحدث نشاطات
زلزاليه على مدار الساعه في المناطق
الزلزاليه فلا بد هذه المعلومات ان تكون
داخل في تحديث كود او دستور البناء
باضافه الى كما ذكر ضيفك هناك تحديث
للمواد ومعرفه مواد جديده تدخل في البناء
يعني هذا حقيقه موضوع هام جدا يعني كما
راينا في الزلزال الذي حدث قبل اسبوعين
بعض المباني هدمت تماما تماما وفي المقابل
بعضها لم يهدم حتى ان الزجاج تلك المباني
لم يتكسر فهناك حقيقه عوامل
ادت الى ذلك ليس فقط المباني هناك عمل
اخرى يعني يجب مراعاتها عند
البناء او عند التصميم او عندك تنفيذ
كمثلا الطبيعه الجيولوجيه لها دور جدا مهم
في البناء حيث
تكون الطبقه الصخريه التي يبنى عليها كلما
كانت صلبه كلما كانت البناء افضل فهذا
عامل مهم جدا بالاضافه الى الى الى المواد
الداخله في البناء فنعم يعني
يجب مراجعه هذه الدساتير حتى تكون يعني
مناسبه هنا في الاردن حقيقه تم تحديث
وتطوير كود البناء الاردني المقاوم لافعال
الزلازل في نسخته 20 22 طبعا تم تتبع
وعمل هذا الكود على افضل
المعايير ولكن كما اسلفت
ضيفك الكريم مدى تطبيق ذلك ومدى معرفه انه
سوف يتم التطبيق هناك مساله اخرى هناك
ابنيه موجوده قبل قبل وجود الدستور البناء
فهذا ايضا بحاجه الى مراجعه وتقييم حتى
يتم معرفه ما مدى يعني مقاومه هذه افعال
الزلازل ما رايك استاذ مظهر هل دولنا
مهيئه للزلازل
نعم يعني نحن لاحظنا بالفتره ان الانظمه
والقوانين الموضوعه هي كانت مرحليه لبعض
الحالات بعد
حدود زلزال تركيا وتاثرت فيه يجب اعاده
النظر في القوانين والدساتر كما ذكر ضيفك
وهي الكودات والكودات بكافه اشكالها هناك
تطور للمواد ولا يجب ان نهمل موضوع التربه
كما ذكر صديقي التربه نوع مهم جدا هناك
تحت باطن الارض يوجد تربه لا يعلمها الا
الله وهي صندوق مغلق يجب الكشف عنها فعاده
عند تنفيذ اي بناء يجب ان يتم سبور لمناطق
متعدده لانه العقار الواحد او الارض
الواحد يمكن ان تكون مؤلفه من اكثر من نوع
من التربه جزء منها صخري وقد يكون جزء
منها غضاري وقد يكون هناك جزء كلسي فليست
الارض على طبيعه معينه اذا لم يكن يؤخذ
بين الاعتبار
دراسه عميقه للتربه بعد حدوث الزلازل وهنا
احب ان انوه بعد الزلزال الذي يجب اعاده
النظر في جميع المباني وخاصه التعليميه
والصحيه القديمه يجب ان تعاد النظر فيها
الى تدعيمها زلزاليا حتى ما نصل لمرحله
هذه المرحله طبعا لا السكن ايضا مهم لكن
انا اكون على المدارس وهذه الابني قد تكون
استاذ مظهر قبل اعاده النظر في هذه
المباني وهذه الجزئيه ونقطه جدا مهمه من
الاساس المباني الموجوده حاليا هل هناك
احترام لهذه المعايير بحسب تقديراتك بحسب
تطلع حضرتك على الموضوع او اطلاع حضرتك
على الموضوع هل هناك احترام في بلدان
العربيه لهذه المعايير كما يجب لن نتحدث
عن استثناءات عن مقاول يعني لا يحترم عمله
عن رخصه تعطى بطريقه هذه تبقى استثناءات
ولكن في المجمل في الدول العربيه هناك
اعطاء حيث
كافي لهذه التهديدات تعتقد
اعتقد نعم هناك بالنظريه نعم على الواقع
في اهمال لبعض لماذا ساذكر ثلاث حالات
الاولى ان المكتب الدارس المهندس دارس هو
يجب ان يكون مختلف عن المهندس مشرف يجب ان
يكون على المهندس منفذ يعني لكل من هو
مسؤوليه لا يجب ان يكون نفسه المهندس
الدارس والمنفذ والمشرف واحد وجهه واحده
يجب ان يكون طرف اخر من يراقب هذا التنفيذ
نحن مشكلتنا ان الجهات المقاوله لديها
فريق ممكن ان تهمل جانب التنفيذ ويقدم
هناك فساد عقاري ايضا كما يعني الابنيه
التي وقعت ليست وقعت لوحدها دون يعني بكل
كما ذكرت حديثه جديده ابنيه جدا متطوره
هناك اهالي مع الاسف يعني تحدثوا وبحرقه
شديده اعطوا كل اموالهم للاستثمار في هذه
البيوت لانها بيوت جدا متطوره وفي بنايات
حديثه وفي الاخير هدمت
يعني بس هذكر انه الابني الحكوميه في في
تركيا لم تهدم منها ولا بناء وهذا ان هناك
معيار مطابق
القطاع الخاص هو الذي تم انهيار اما
الابنيه لماذا لم تنهار ولا بناء حكومي في
تركيا سقط لابنيه المؤسسات الحكوميه اذا
هناك قد يكون في جهات رقابيه الجهه منفذه
وجهه مشرفه وقد يوافقني الدكتور محمود نحن
هناك خلط يعني نحن بنشوف الاطباء يدخل
الجراح لوحده ومن ثم المخدر لوحده كل واحد
مسؤول عن قصب الاقسام لماذا نحن نخيمن على
كل الاقسام يجب ان نترك الدرس بجهه ونرقق
الدراسه الدراسه بعض الدراسات غير مدقه
دول تدقق وبعضها تعتمد على مهندس دارس فقط
وهناك الاشراف الطرف الاخر الذي يكون رقيب
وهناك الجهه المقاوله هو الاضعف الا يجب
ان ينفذ وليس المقاول الاقوى الاضعف
والمقاول على كل هذه الاجهزه وهنا سؤال
حضرتك دكتور محمود
هناك العديد من المتدخلين في هذا الاطار
هناك من يقيم التربه هناك من يقيم المواد
الاساسيه هناك من يقدم الرخص هناك من يشرف
على طريقه البناء ولكن من يجب ان تكون له
اليد العليا
لمتابعه ومراقبه كل هذه التفاصيل
اعتقد يجب ان تكون هناك يعني اما هيئه او
او يعني بصفه ما تسميه لا تهم لكن تكون
ذات صبغه وصفه حكوميه ملزمه تتابع التصميم
والتنفيذ والمراقبه لانه الامر لا يحتمل
لا يحتمل ان تكون الامور بين هنا وهناك
يجب ان تكون هذه الهيئه تحت مظله
اعلى اعلى مظله حكوميه وهذا غير متوفر في
دولنا العربيه
نعم نعم هذا غير متوفر اعتقد يجب ان تكون
هناك هيئات ملزمه
تتخذ صفات حكوميه حتى يتم المراقبه بجد
ومحاسبه المخالفين فاذا لم تتم المحاسبه
اعتقد هناك يعني يبقى الخلل سنبقى في
متابعه الجزء الثاني من هذا الموضوع وهو
جزء جدا مهم جزء النفسي ولكن ساكتفي معكم
بهذا القدر على ان تتابعانا ربما بعد قليل
من عمان الدكتور محمود القريوتي الباحث
والمختص في علم ورصد الزلازل ومن اسطنبول
المهندس الاستشاري مظهر شربشي شكرا لكما